en numéro 4 dans les sujets qui vous ont
intéressé il ya les propos de bernard
montiel sur laëtitia l'idée qui font
polémique
hier dans tpm paix on a décidé au stade
ou encore on avait décidé de revenir sur
les tv de laeticia hallyday dans sept à
huit et sujet vous avez sorti vous avez
fait sortir de vos gonds
bernard montiel temps bernard montiel
est énervé oui il perd même son bronzage
n'est pas épargné la veuve du rockeur
vous est même allé jusqu'à la qualifier
d'actrice on va regarder vos propos mais
c'est vrai que ça a énormément réagi sur
les réseaux sociaux regarde là il faut
avouer que c'était extrêmement émouvant
si on se laisse piéger
enfin cap c'est extrêmement choquant
quand on connaît bien tout ce qui s'est
passé dans cette nuit là bon voila moi
j'étais très choquée de de ce discours
là elle est venu juste pour faire la
promotion de ce coffret qui sort
vendredi prochain uniquement pour ça
elle ne veut plus venir en france
puisqu'elle n'a rien à [ __ ] de la
france maintenant quatre fois ce qu'elle
a dit elle à la maison et pour moi quand
elle dit jeu hors du mal à toucher à
notre homme roux bon quoi bah je sais
pas non je sais pas quand elle part
d'exploiter l'image de johnny j'ai envie
de continuer à faire vivre johnny dans
le coeur des hommes
oui comme ça pourra continuer à aller
chez chanel et dans les grands
restaurants
moi je marche pas dans sa combine elle
est lamentable cette combine est elle un
bon mois ça ne marche pas alors c'est
vrai que ça fait énormément parler
bernard scoop confirmé beau je confirme
je maintiens il n'y a aucun problème
je comprends que ça puisse choquer mais
si vous voulez quand moi j'ai connu
laetitia j'ai quand même le dire j'ai
connu les tissus indiqué qu'elle est une
fille adorable qui a eu beaucoup de mal
à s'intégrer auprès de la vie de johnny
c'était vraiment un petit bébé quand
elle était arrivée et la vie johnny
n'était pas facile et fréquenté une star
une rock star
c'était pas évident elle a été
extrêmement mignon extrêmement gentil et
puis heureusement elle est devenue une
femme heureusement elle a évolué elle a
vu un peu tout ce qui se passe dans la
vie d'une star et c'est très compliqué
elle a eu du mérite j'ai toujours dit
sauf que moi il ya un truc qui n'est
jamais passé c'est qu'on déshérités
enfants c'est tout et je ne suis pas le
porte parole ni de l'oranie de david
donc je tiens à le redire c'est tout ce
qui m'a dérangé elle a monté tout le
coup et là quand elle revient maintenant
genre avec sa petite voix et tout ça ça
marche pas je la connais par coeur
sa petite voix la pompe pour la télé ou
à la lande humide et heureuse alors
arrêtez vous
une enquête commence comme on dit ouais
ok c'est josé da your breath away
non elle est différente c'est une c
c'est une manipulatrice je les ai déjà
dit je vais pas le redire mais vous êtes
vous êtes plus du tout potentiel
non je vous entendez bien avec l alibori
allait bien et qu'elle est arrivée là
dedans
moi j'étais un des seul là-dedans c'est
quoi la démarche dans le milieu kaka
était arrivé à saint tropez la première
fois moi je les aime et je les mêmes
connu un violent parce que d'alors
généralement je vous le dis aux
téléspectateurs dès que vous arrivez à
saint tropez
la première personne que vous croisez
c'est bien la voilà dans 17 janvier
gâteau il est au péage
voilà donc un don qui disait si tu vois
montiel à saint tropez c'est comme
mickey à disneyland
voilà ça m'a beaucoup amusé à écouter je
vois vos dîners de gelée soutenu j'étais
très copain avec elle parce que c'était
très difficile
johnny était quand même assez solides à
il fallait quand même avoir beaucoup de
forces pour lutter contre lui et avec
lui donc elle a réussi après à ce format
t elle est devenue très forte
et maintenant voilà a voulu garder tout
le pognon et ben non il ya des enfants
il faut que tout le monde touche et déjà
déjà de russie voilà donc c'est pour ça
que ça m'a énervé depuis le départ mais
je l'aimé beaucoup avant mais benjamin
castaldi mais je vais soutenir la vie
des stars mais la vérité il a raison
vers la ja et ayala laetitia que les
gens imaginent le public et elle est
issue tel-aviv quand même on peut dire
ainsi quand même pour les
téléspectateurs aussi mon ami des biens
mais bon le 2 mai masse mais le jeu vous
dire il voit pas bien il s'est cramé
d'avis qu'elle est ici
moi j'ai la chance de connaître un peu
un peu denis de connaître un peu de
proches de johnny de connaître un peu
des gens qui connaissent le couple et
c'est vrai qu'il a raison bernard faut
pas le laonnois
il ya vraiment là laetitia que les gens
imaginent et celles qui dans la vie
maintenant c'est pas grave
chacun fait sa vie mais c'est vrai
qu'elle son numéro son numéro à
l'émission de ces petites voix et est
l'homme qui ne touche pas et qu'une
couche plus toucherait plus fâché on a
rien compris de façon mais mais voilà
faut pas nous raconter ça faut avoir un
peu de décence à thé vide voilà c'est ce
que fait bernard que tu détestes et issa
c'est une chose
come back to be c'est pas elle qui a
déshérité ses enfants c'est johnny qui
les a pas mis sur son héritage on ne
sait pas les petits sacs est responsable
de ça alors ça du plâtre et mieux fait
lui dire qu'on était avec elle à sa
barque ont été invités à partager leurs
ici drame
plutôt que de dire maintenant maintenant
qu'il est parti quelques personnes pour
de toutes les positions
je sais quand on est très malade et
qu'on n'a pas envie de s'emmerder johnny
n'a rarement affronter les difficultés
c'est un mec qui laissait couler parce
que les par me collant merde et quand
elle allait prendre des versions qui
supportait métissage qui n'avait pas
envie de s'emmerder
non je n'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit
simplement que c'est sa veuve et
l'orphelin je peux terminer
tranquillement gilles vous le
connaissiez pas moi je le connaissais
très bien
il n'avait pas envie qu'on emmerde
n'avais pas envie de soucis donc du coup
à la fin il s'est laissé un peu fait et
tu crois qu'il aimerait bien entendre ce
que tu dis ma tante ça oui je crois que
même bien battu mais il a mille fois
raison bien sûr bien sûr dillon montant
qui était mon grand père qui était
pareil il voulait dire pourtant oui oui
qu'on voulait pas qu'on boit on lui
répète emmerder parler des [ __ ] quand
tu dis alors que tu as fait tes papiers
ou dit bah écoute et faites ce que vous
voulez je suis sûre elle sait exactement
ce qu'il a faire le 19 ou c'est ce que
vous avez fait également avec mes yeux
mes mails avec notamment il a déjà tout
laisser à ses ex femmes
non mais c'est vrai que je comprends
très bien je pense que johnny il n'avait
pas envie qu'on emmerde avec son ami
c'est surtout il voulait faire dé sa
peau apprendre à rené malleville qui est
très bien placé social énormément dans
ce que dit bernard et j'ai été choqué
c'est qu'en fait sans le dire il donne
le point de vue de david et laura à
idées ni à l'éthicien au nom d'un passé
qu'il évoque
mais sans nous dire ce qui s'est passé
comme s'il ya eu des choses pas pauline
alors si vous ne pouvez pas le dire vous
ne vous entendez pas des monstres et moi
ça me gêne les sous-entendus et ils
dénient à laëtitia le droit de se
reconstruire
comme si elle n'avait pas le droit je
dis il faut juger faut juger sur
l'avenir j'ai dit au figaro aujourd'hui
qu'ils avaient guerlain 83 ans qui était
libre ou ici elle va avec
comme ça on sera n'y va pas c'est que
c'est une femme sinon y'a relève albi
bernard lui qui lui collait bd parce que
c'est celui qui connaît le mieux le
mieux la connaître
j'atteins jamais parlé du père de
laeticia qui parlait qu'à toujours foutu
la merde au mythe de par le couple au
surcoût alors et sur la fortune
maintenant il a été c'était aller retour
à un moment johnny même voulais que ce
soit le père qui gère les affaires après
il a été viré après il s'est fâché avec
laeticia
laëtitia avait menti il l'a dit dans la
presse qu'elle avait menti qu'il avait
qu'elle avait même recréé une forme de
légende au niveau de leur rencontre
il n'était pas la plus brillante non
plus et puis après il est revenu
maintenant que lui est parti à les
revenus se sont ré entendu si tant mieux
mais si vous voulez c'est très compliqué
cette affaire et je regrette qu'à chaque
fois on revienne là-dessus je dis
simplement que quand les enfants ils
voulaient voir leur père mourant
on leur a interdit de le voir déjà et en
plus ils ont été déshérités ce qui est
pas normal quand on connaît l'amour de
johnny pour ses enfants
merci en tout cas bernard ont fait
d'être revenu voilà là dessus et de
garder votre ligne
[Applaudissements]